et voilà à vous peut-être d'apporter
d'autres éclaircissements en tout cas ce
que votre imagination formeront au cours
de cette émission nous avons eu deux
interruptions de l'image dont nous vous
demandons de vouloir bien nous excuser
et maintenant vous savez qu'à 22h 15
nous avons rendez vous avec les coureurs
du tour de france
résumé films et de la 6e étape de ce
43ème tour de france mais en attendant
nous allons voir un petit film un film
de courts métrages jean jacques cornu
qui a pour titre la couronne de paris
soir téléspectateurs de la deuxième
chaîne j'espère que vous avez pu
profiter des conseils de vos radios
électricien pour vérifier cet après midi
le réglage de vaud récepteur voici le
programme que vous pourrez recevoir ce
soir sur le canal 22 bancs de 4,625
ligne à partir de 20h30
tout d'abord un film burlesque de court
métrage de la série félix de christian
duval ex
un quart d'heure plus tard une émission
de variétés de daniel labre réalisé par
jean charles l'agneau qui a pour titre
trois années trois succès ensuite de 21h
à 21h50 opéra croquis le petit musicien
d'après penney scénario et dialogues
pierre gillot et emile noël réalisation
jean marie coll de fille
rendez vous si vous le désirez à 20h30
sur la deuxième chaîne ce soir au revoir
et à tout à l'heure
bonjour mesdames bonjour mademoiselle
bonjour messieurs unis civilement au
prince rainier de monaco
mademoiselle kelly est depuis hier
madame grimaldi mais ce n'est
qu'aujourd'hui après les cérémonies
religieuses qu'elle deviendra princesse
grace de monaco
nous allons assister à la messe
solennelle qui sera dite par monseigneur
gilles barthes évêque de la principauté
reportage pierre sabbagh commentaires
claude darget
deux émissions en direct vous attendent
maintenant grâce à la première nous
serons pourquoi et comment nos petites
pièces blanches d'aujourd'hui ont une
valeur indiscutable en effet c'est ce
que vous expliquera claude darget dans
cette émission réalisée par hubert knapp
en direct de l'hôtel de la monnaie
et puis à 21h10 georges de caunes nous
recevra à l' agence france-presse
et vous verrez la vie d'une grande
agence de presse qui vit pour vous 24
heures par jour qui travaillent pour
vous 24 heures par jour cette émission
sera réalisée par igor barrère
deuxième candidat première prise
mademoiselle la 7e tandis date vous
appeler anne marie peysson vous avez
quel âge et 22 ans j'avais votre
profession je suis depuis trois ans
piquerait la télé marseille la maison
des risques
bon quel est notre formation aux
scolaires ou universitaires
je me suis arrêté à la première partie
du bachot parce que je suis entré à la
télévision à ce moment là bon vous
balader dans un projet l'anglais est un
petit peu l'espagnol l'anglais pas mal
de l'angleterre ou sessegnon dans le bus
on verra ça tout à leur mercie voulez
vous mettre très lentement tourner la
tête sur la gauche de façon nous
présenter votre profil droit martyrs
étendard et permet la bouche
revenez vers nous le joli sourire au
passage voilà de l'autre côté c'est ça
revenez bombe date deuxième épreuve pour
mademoiselle on vous a donné il ya une
vingtaine de minutes un texte à en
porter que le programme type d'une
journée télévision vous les voyez le
dire c'est loupé bonjour chers amis et
bien dans quelques instants nous
retrouverons jacques schab années roger
ferrals qui nous attendent au bar de
télé paris comme chaque jour et leur
émission sera suivie à 13h15 de dernière
heure et du journal télévisé la
troisième diffusion du journal télévisé
mais si vous voulez bien auparavant
nous allons jeter un petit coup d'oeil
sur ce que sera le programme de cette
journée
tout d'abord cet après midi de 14h à
14h30
l'émission scolaire on y parlera
aujourd'hui du costume civil et
militaire à rome
le programme de la soirée commencera à
19h30 avec économie et industrie une
émission de nice soyez lavergne et
charles corrèze
réalisé par solange peters à 20h fidèles
et consacrés à aux pêcheurs roulante et
à 20h fidèles du feuilleton vous
retrouverez votre héros le colonel march
et au cours de ce nouvel épisode je
pense qu'il vous fera encore les témoin
de sa de son flair infaillible à 20h40
nous nous rendrons à londres pour
retrouver jacques salbert qui pendant
quelques minutes nous entretiendra et à
20h50
nous reviendrons dans nos studios d'où
nous vous présenterons une pièce de
somerset maugham adapté pour la
télévision par jacques chabal la lettre
c'est une réalisation de jean paul
carrère à 22h10 nous avons un rendez
vous avec jacqueline joubert qui elle
même en a fixé à à jacques brel et enfin
à 22 heures
alexandre tartas j'ai oublié et à 22h40
raymond thevenaz au cours de sa tribune
nous parlera de la circulation nous on
exposera tous les problèmes c'est tout
un programme je crois n'oublions pas à
20h15 et en fin de soirée les dernières
heures et le journal télévisé geste il
réalise des débuts de circulation jean
gillet gandhi s'est pas terminée on
bâtira téléparis passé 5/7 candidate
troisième prise malgré ce on vous a
donné les éléments de la non ce dont la
grande émission du soir que vous avez pu
apprendre soit parker soit tourné à
votre façon à votre idée voulez vous
nous annoncer sa démission
et maintenant place au théâtre c'est une
oeuvre de somerset morgan que jacques
chabal a adapté pour la télévision que
nous vous proposons de regarder ce soir
réalisé dans nos studios par jean paul
carrère ce drame car il s'agit d'un
gramme a pour cadre une île de la
malaisie
il a pour sujet un cas est étonnant de
dissimulation féminine et il est mené un
petit peu à la façon d'une pièce
policière
mais je laisse ça à l'adaptateur jacques
chabal le soin de vous présenter mieux
que moi oeuvre et interprète
merci septième candidat quatrième rang
pour mademoiselle il y a deux minutes
on vous a appris que l'émission prévue
pour ce soir le couvert leurs yeux pour
une voix indépendante volontaire vous
attendez tous les éléments de cette
annonce vous voulez vous improvisez
votre annonce d' excuses
eh bien nous devons ce soir vous
présentez transmis depuis nos studios
une pièce de somerset maugham adapté
pour la télévision par jacques chabal il
s'agissait de la lettre malheureusement
l'interprète principale vient de tomber
malade et nous nous trouvons dans
l'obligation de ne pas vous présenter
cette émission nous espérons que vous
voudrez bien nous en excuser et nous
vous proposons en remplacement un grand
film il s'agit d'un western c'est à dire
que grands et petits trouveront
certainement beaucoup de plaisir et vous
pourrez entendre siffler l'assaut vous
pourrez assister un nombre de bagarres
je crois que vous vous amuserez beaucoup
voici terreur en oklahoma c'était vous
avez du talent vous avez appris un peu
l'anglais et l'espagnol
voulez-vous me dire en anglais ce que
l'on voit sur tout et partir de wagons
il est dangereux de se pencher it
dangerous to line out bon et en espagnol
voulez-vous me dire colomb de mon coeur
pas l'armada l'allemagne paloma des
landes mamiya encore une fois pas
l'homme adalah le mamiya c'est sa merci
le septième candidat de cinquième
épreuve non
j'habite au avec nous asseoir ne
bougeait plus ouvrier c'est très bien
redon et soyons confiants et en ce 24
décembre bien il sera d'abord question
du train de noël vous allez avoir un
aperçu de l'ensemble dans quelques
instants
pourquoi nous aurons des petits papiers
à la main parce que c'est extrêmement
compliqué oui partant de bruxelles via
lille arras et amiens pour paris qui
sera sa destination
notre train de noël sera conduit par
jean nohain et toute son équipe
habituelle qui proposeront des
distractions et des jeux pendant tout le
parcours c'est à dire à l'intérieur du
train aux voyageurs ces voyageurs et
bien ce seront essentiellement et des
grands-pères belge qui partiront en
quarts de bruxelles pendant que se
déroulera à paris marie-claude avec
leurs petits enfants et ils arriveront
de cette façon à lire mais par
anticipation si vous voulez bien nous
allons imaginer que nous sommes le
samedi 24 décembre et il est 13h45 c'est
à ce moment là que le train de noël
prend le départ de lille voilà le départ
est pris je dois ajouter que le
réalisateur c'est à dire alexandre
tartas et assurer la participation d'un
hélicoptère
c'était extrêmement compliqué comment
vouliez-vous pouvoir suivre le spectacle
à bord du train sans un relais
absolument indispensable donc tout cela
se déroulera dans le train et nous
allons de ce fait arriver maintenant à
arras
après le journal télévisé de 20h 15 et
le départ des jouets des cinq mille
colis de la rtf abords du coche d'eau au
mouillage à la concorde pierre tchernia
et alexandre tartas nous gratifie dans
une ambiance très britannique du noël de
sherlock holmes
ensuite une visite aussi inattendue que
sympathique celle de jean gabin la
distribution des jouets continue mais à
21h10 yvan audouard arrive à l'écran
avec sa pastorale qu'a réalisé jean prat
et à 21h55 c'est la balançoire de
balthazar de denise glaser réalisé par
pierre vial est avec danielle darrieux
et charles aznavour
eh bien il est temps maintenant de
quitter merlimont les animateurs et les
invités de cette émission pour rendre
l'antenne à paris qui va vous proposer à
14 heures précises la télévision
scolaire
je vous rappel lors de vos actualités
régionales 19h15 et également que demain
sur la seconde chaîne de 14h à 14h30
vous pourrez suivre le magazine du
mineur bonne après midi à bientôt
les spectateurs téléspectateurs de
provence côte d'azur corse bonsoir cette
mission se termine je vous souhaite de
passer une bonne soirée un agréable
dimanche au revoir
je
ats
nicole
solutionner le problème de la condition
humaine par la force les conquêtes par
la sagesse l'écran rennes par l'amour le
christianisme par les opioïdes autant
d'échecs
mais aujourd'hui la science nous propose
la loi de la statistique des machines
cybernétique pourraient être des
gouvernants bien plus impartiaux que le
meilleur des hommes vasarely
et vous faites moins de limites même
s'il ya quelque chose parce que les
knicks à part ça c'est trop ça fait
amicaux faux faux pas comme ça sublime
et et quand vous avez un geste apple
facebook ou les années par un cinquième
essai pas sur une scène qui vend donc ça
pouvait durer cette ligne comme ça ne
veut pas dire
solutionner le problème de la condition
humaine par la farce les conquêtes par
la sagesse dans les grands règne pas
l'amour le christianisme par les opium
autant d'échecs
mais aujourd'hui la science de propose
la loi de la statistique
les machines cybernétique pourraient
être des gouvernants bien plus
impartiaux que le meilleur des hommes
vasarely
ah ah ouais
notre ami john mack arctique et
professeur à l'université de standford
poursuit ses recherches dans le domaine
de l'intelligence artificielle
attention les singes les robots vous
rattrape le nouvel avis est que nous
avons ce soir est un chercheur bien sûr
qui cherche sa voie entre les scènes de
théâtre et la biochimie macromoléculaire
sur la scène son nom et georges balle
mais entre nous nous l'appelons docteur
dr balla ça j'aime beaucoup que vous
parlez mais certains pensent que je
parle trop
certains chercheurs voudrais me
remplacer par une machine
c'est tout ce que je sais y passer
sur la lancée d'un faut viser la ration
à cause de carrément et de me dire
pourquoi vous aimez les sciences
ça donne
moi j'ai une science parce que la
science c'est quand même
françois n'est pas quelque chose qui me
vient à l'esprit
30e monde
où
moi j'aime les sciences je reconnais les
sciences dans le domaine de la sécurité
le domaine quand on se perd dans les
méandres de la littérature ou de la
philosophie des problèmes d'une
difficulté d'une un peu d'assurance tout
le monde peut assurer n'importe quoi
alors que les sciences sont là avec leur
pivot rassurant leurs preuves
leur identification leur vérification
dans tous les domaines leurs
applications extraordinaire tant dans la
science naturelle que dans les sciences
appliquées on s'y retrouve on retrouve
alors on se sent tout d'un coup plus
leur univers qu'on ne comprend pas un
univers de phénomènes contradictoires
retrouve une ligne et cette ligne si la
science voilà pourquoi j'aime les
sciences
on ne sait plus
poses avantageuses un parent autour des
sciences
on a beaucoup parlé des femmes et de
leur goût pour la littérature pour la
littérature fantastique je n'y crois pas
ou alors ils cherchent là une fausse
féminité la véritable femme l'avait la
féminité et scientifique
elle retrouve là un pivot une nécessité
quelque chose qui la justifient elles
mêmes
elle est alors allée reconnue dans le
domaine de du fantastique de littérature
de la philosophie et se perd un peu elle
même dans le domaine de la science on
retrouve une spontanéité aussi
il sourit et soulier manche un peu la
guerre
poupée
pour au stade de roland garros mais
auparavant je tiens à vous signaler que
le reportage cyclistes que nous devions
voir à 15h45 nous le verrons en fait un
petit peu plus tôt c'est en effet vers
15h30 que nous nous rendrons à chambéry
pour assister à l'arrivée de l'étape du
jour du critérium des six provinces en
effet les cyclistes ont pris un petit
peu d'avancé
nous nous rendons maintenant donc au
stade roland garros doute christian
quidet jean reynal devons nous commenter
sur des images de daniel tomasi les
internationaux de france
richard merci jean claude s'est bien
battue ce je suis fou de musique
dorothée je suis fou de musique
je sais que vous savez dans ces parce
qu'on vous a vu la semaine dernière mais
savez vous chantez oum et dorothée oui
un jour je vous ferai écouter un
deuxième favori oui d'ailleurs que si
vous voulez je peux le faire tout de
suite non mathis nous avons un programme
bien chargé aujourd'hui à bompas de
dommages nous allons commencer donc
voilà 16h24 le chevalier plus notre
chevalier bleus sera soumis à une
épreuve très difficile c'est de
affronter une grosse salamandre oui on
va la réussite de son entreprise ne fait
aucun doute
à 16h36 vous ferez connaissance avec
notre ami céleri oui c'est un brave
lions britanniques qui cherchent un
moyen de locomotion courbe active en
batterie à 16h43 l'enfant et le sport ah
oui c'est une émission que vous
connaissez tous maintenant vous ferez
connaissance à cabourg avec une jeune
servante du tennis de table
ah oui la petite catherine ha oui elle
est très jeune mais je crois qu'elle
initie aussi des plus jeunes qu'elles à
ce sport marc fois doit être très
difficile à 17h11 l'époux stuff cookies
le héros de cette histoire grâce à une
fleur magique est devenu tout petit
petit petit oui ce qui lui permet de
visiter le village
ni attire des poux stuff qui entre nous
et bien à leur dimension
ah oui pardon
eh bien je pense qu'après les pouces top
c'est 17h17 exactement avec le pays de
l'arc en ciel c'est ça aujourd'hui c'est
une mine abandonnée dentition à question
et après avoir vu un écran
oui c'est une mine abandonnée oui je
voulais parler du rom au record de la
semaine dernière qui avait été perdu à
bien oui et aujourd'hui c'est une mine
abandonnée par des choses très bizarres
oui oui on veut nous verrons ça tout à
l'heure à 17h40 et une tête en friche
oui il s'agit je crois d'une famille
très strict oui oui qui nous fait
partager un repas très surprenant en
1930 et à 17h49 vous aurez le petit
conservatoire à huy dong wei a très bien
très bien et n'oublions pas notre ennui
le docteur mais nous allons commencer
dès maintenant avec le chevalier bleus
voilà le chevalier bleus regarde
1975 c'est tf1 c'est aussi l'arrivée à
paris ce matin de christine freesia à
droite et d'evelyne leclerc à gauche
elles ont 24 et 25 ans elles viennent de
notre station régionale de nice côte
d'azur pour en quelque sorte animé et re
soirée sur tf1
speakerine nice une première comment
concevez vous votre rôle de télé
speakerine
eh bien on va essayer je crois dans la
mesure du possible de faire quelque
chose de tout à fait nouveau on nous a
demandés nous intéressait beaucoup plus
aux émissions qui sont présentés
d'assister aux projections de presse de
faire
on intervient aussi en fin de prêt fait
je pense qu'une participation
personnelle beaucoup plus important que
nous apporterons notre avis et
raconteront les anecdotes qui se seront
passées au moment du tournage ou bien
nous donnerons jugement personnel sur
telle ou telle émission
vous pensez avoir des invités par
exemple oui c'est très peu si je peux
les réalisateurs des missions bien des
les artistes et gens qui participent à
l'émission si nous passons un film très
connus essayer d'avoir la vedette
principale ou bien le metteur en scène
je pense que ça intéressera les gens va
un petit peu l'envers du décor d'une
émission qui est présenté les premiers
pas de cette nouvelle formule dès le
premier jour de tf1 rendez vous donc
avec christine freesia et evelyne
leclercq lundi 6
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir et je souhaite que vous passiez
avec nous un très agréable moment
vous avez certainement suivi les
précédents épisodes de la série qui
retrace la vie de marie-antoinette entre
1769 et jusqu'à sa mort et bien ce soir
nous allons voir le quatrième et dernier
épisode de cette série réalisée par guy
andré lefranc et c'est geneviève casile
qui joue le rôle de marie antoinette
quels sont les rapports entre la
médecine et le sport et plus précisément
le football eh bien ce sera ce soir à
22h05 le thème de l'émission médical
d'igor barrère pierre des groupes et
étienne le loup et pour participer à
cette émission et bien nous aurons la
présence de l'équipe de football de race
est célèbre équipe qui à part donc prêté
son concours à cette émission pour des
tests pour des études médicales et vous
venez d'entendre 7 à 23 heures que
julien besançon nous présentera son
journal la france en 1792 la vie et les
derniers moments de marie-antoinette
c'est ce que nous allons vivre
maintenant avec la quatrième et dernière
partie de cette série
marie antoinette
cet après midi restez donc avec nous les
missions de maurice bruzac et eve
ruggieri réalisé par jean-pierre walid
nous propose un programme très fourni
avec herbert pagani pour les variétés le
premier épisode d'un nouveau feuilleton
mauregard un aperçu du rallye auto-moto
côte d'azur côte d'ivoire
une page de cinéma et un invité
d'honneur rené goscinny qui viendra vous
parlez de son héros lucky luke
nous allons retrouver dans quelques
instants une minute pour les femmes les
missions des lianes victor mais
auparavant j'aimerais vous rappeler nos
principaux rendez vous de la soirée
tout d'abord à 19h45 nous pourrons
suivre le dixième épisode du feuilleton
de jean-pierre richard iii de coeur à
20h30 nous irons au théâtre pour voir
une comédie en noir et blanc de gabri à
la roue déjà diffusée le 4 juin 1970 et
intitulé deux fois deux fonds 5 et les
quatre acteurs que nous retrouverons
seront alain pralon michel grellier
michel roux et colette castel puis après
la dernière édition de tf1 actualité
c'est à dire à 22h45
nous irons à montréal pour assister en
direct à diverses épreuves des jeux
olympiques mais pour le moment je cède
la place à anne marie peysson
bonsoir en raison de la grève du
personnel d'un tel que nous appliquons
aujourd'hui le programme minimum prévu
c'est ainsi que notre programme de ce
soir se composera d'un film que vous
verrez dans quelques instants et d'une
émission de jazz ce fait nous ses quatre
balles ou un film américain d'elliot
silverstein avec jane fonda lee marvin
dans les rôles principaux
ainsi que le regretté nat king cole que
vous verrez tout au long du film chanté
la balade de quatre balles où il s'agit
d'un western nettement ou parodiques
dont les personnages sont très
pittoresque particulièrement celui qu
interprète l'hymne arfi et puis on est
aux alentours de 22 heures un petit peu
avant de 22 heures un spécial benny
carter émission de gens qu'ils soient
avertis consacré au saxophoniste
clarinettiste et trompettiste ainsi que
chef d'orchestre benny carter il n'y
aura pas de dernier journal ce soir en
raison d'un grève bien sûr c'est donc
après cette émission de jazz que se
terminera notre programme mais tout de
suite je vous laisse faire la
connaissance de quatre mètres bonne
soirée
puisque nous allons passer cette soirée
ensemble autant la rendre très agréable
pour commencer de la musique avec un
concert donné par l'orchestré
philharmonique de berlin sous la
direction d'herbert von karajan alexis
weissenberg va interpréter ce soir le
concerto numéro 2 pour piano en ut
mineur de rachmaninov
puis à partir de 21h10 notez-bien 21h10
georges arnaud et georges ferraro vous
proposeront une grande enquête sur la
sphère moon une enquête ils ont mené aux
quatre coins du monde à bord aux états
unis où vit fastueusement celui que l'on
appelle le révérend moon puis en corée
du sud où est né le monisme en france et
au japon il a essaimé de nouveaux
éléments de réponses arriveront
peut-être à éclaircir cette affaire
23h15 on vient de vous dire ce sera
l'heure de la toute dernière actualité
présenté et commenté par bernard à la
soirée commence place à la musique avec
je vous le rappelle ce concert donné par
l'orchestré philharmonique de berlin
sous la direction d'herbert von karajan
bonsoir
si vous le désirez nous allons voir ce
soir une comédie américaine réalisée par
melvil chapelle sonne qui réunit carrie
gang et sophia loren un cary grant du
distingué que j'avais et une sophia
loren qui fait ses débuts dans la
comédie américaine auprès d'un
partenaire que lui envient
d'authentix d'art du pays parce que en
1951 donner la réplique à cary grant et
un honneur chèrement disputées
quand une belle dame italienne pleine de
charme vient tout exprès séduire un
monsieur américain type
eh bien ça donne une histoire d'amour
pleine de charme et de gaieté quand il y
a des sentiments il ya quelquefois des
larmes mais elle s'est vite parce que
cette péniche et la péniche du bonheur
le spectacle peut commencer
voyons la péniche nous avons même si ça
n'est pas exactement celle du film elle
est très belle tout de même le bonheur
ça pourrait être d'être ensemble ce soir
quant à la comédie
elle arrive d'outre-atlantique dans un
instant je vous rappelle que le journal
de jean marie cavada terminera notre
soirée
savez peut-être ils ont été créés
imaginée par le dessinateur jean michel
folon est aujourd'hui pour commencer
cette nouvelle année
antenne 2 vous proposera tout au cours
de ce 1er janvier de retrouver l'univers
de jean michel folon à travers des
chansons interprétées par jacques brel
par claude nougaro par yves montand
également des chansons qui ont été
illustrés par des films d'animation
créée par jean michel folon vient pour
commencer notre programme télévisé nous
allons vous présenter dans un instant un
merveilleux concert en concert
interprété par herbert von karajan la
quatrième symphonie de tchaïkovski bon
début de journée sur antenne 2 à tout à
l'heure
oui samedi prochain dans la deuxième
partie de cette émission bien vous
pourrez voir des extraits des comédies
musicales qui ont marqué le cinéma
américain dans les années 1930 1940 avec
bien sûr fred astaire et ginger rogers
cinéma aussi ce soir sur tf1 à 20h30
avec les animaux sont dans la ville
c'est un film de peter hunt l'histoire
d'une petite ville tout à fait
tranquille qui tout à coup voit sa vie
bouleversée par l'arrivée d'animaux
sauvages échappés d'une réserve
il en résulte bien sûr des scènes de
terreur faso au tigré aux ours mais
aussi des scènes comiques est plutôt
inattendue entre autres pour rattraper
les autruches donc ce soir à 20h30 ce
film et puis je vous rappelle aussi qu
après cette projection nous repartirons
en compagnie de l'équipe du commandant
cousteau à la recherche des trésors
perdus et des civilisations perdues
puisque ce soir nous repartirons à la
recherche de l'atlantique voilà donc
pour notre soirée dans quelques instants
le journal tf1 qualité et aujourd'hui
nous allons retrouver yves mourousi
assure end où il va nous présenter le
journal chez une famille de
téléspectateurs
bonjour
dans un instant vous retrouverez le jeu
d'henry kubrick réponse à tout présenté
par carole chabrier et louis besoin
ensuite midi première avec danièle
gilbert qui invitait pour vous
aujourd'hui gilles vigneault et françois
béranger à 13h le journal suivi des
informations régionales
13h50 d'hier et d'aujourd'hui l'émission
de marc brionne et claudine qu'ils
génèrent avec la rubrique ses chers
disparus
nous évoquerons aujourd'hui la fin de la
carrière de luis mariano
14h05 que le cndp vous propose une
chasse photographique en forêt à 14h25
dans le cycle gary cooper qui débute
aujourd'hui et ce pour tous les lundis à
suivre un film d'otto preminger de 1955
condamné au silence
à 16h05 dans le cadre du patrimoine cet
héritage qui est le nôtre aujourd'hui
pour trois traditions populaires qui
sont la littérature de colportage la
chanson et l'imagerie d'epinal jacques
douai est ici mon participent à cette
émission qui a été tourné dans les
vosges par jacques min enfin à 17h40 la
rubrique à votre service par jean claude
vernier aujourd'hui les femmes et la
retraite
quels sont les droits des femmes en
matière de retraite eh bien nous en
saurons plus un peu plus tard voilà
l'émission d'hier et d'aujourd'hui se
termine sur cette séquence pour laisser
la place à 18h à tf 4 l'émission de
françois bonnes mains et de jacques poux
je vous retrouve un peu plus tard pour
vous parler du reste du programme
j'aimerais maintenant vous parler des
programmes de notre soirée que vous
passerez en compagnie de mon ami martin
chardon c'est un beau film que vous
verrez à 20h35 un film de jean daniel de
paulilles acrobates
je vous en reparlerai de ce film dans
une vingtaine de minutes vous
comprendrez pourquoi tout à l'heure et à
22h10 les impressions de tournage des
français en écosse mort en direct
en effet une équipe de la bbc de glace
qu à filmer durant huit semaines le
tournage du film de bertrand tavernier
la mort en direct avec romy schneider et
max von sydow et ce sont ces images que
vous pourrez suivre ce soir avec nous à
22h10 et nous terminerons la soirée avec
une émission que vous connaissez bien de
pierre petit réalisé par gérard exode
figaro si figaro là avec la soprano
michèle koeman esther et le bar et
anthony amis râteau tout de suite c'est
la vie présentée par noël mamère et
claude marcotte et je vous retrouve dans
20 minutes
à tout à l'heure
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en ce
24 décembre une grande partie de
l'après-midi intéressera les enfants en
effet à partir de 15 heures
dorothée vous fera découvrir le pays où
les habitants sont des chansons chansons
tristes chansons gaies gens sont timides
chanson rock chanson d'amour
une comédie musicale donc à 15 heures
avec dorothée au pays des chansons à
15h55
un film un film truculence humour
bagarre avec miou-miou robert charlebois
terence hill qui se livrent à une
parodie de western agit ni une cloche
deux associés 17h50 magie majax les
comédiens et les chanteurs qui seront
auprès de gérard majax devront
absolument savoir faire des tours pour
mériter leurs cadeaux de noël
parmi eux darry cowl karen cheryl alain
bashung
les enfants ne seront pas exclues de la
veillée noël en effet ils seront 2000 à
20h30 à l'opéra de paris assister au
spectacle le qu'animera patrick poivre
d'arvor un spectacle donné par
l'orchestré de l'opéra par les ballets
de l'opéra les petits rats les danseurs
étoiles par des comédiens français tels
que jacques toja enfin par des chanteurs
comme yves duteil et michel berger et
cette joie de noël à l'opéra de paris
s'achèvera sur le lac des cygnes et puis
tout le reste de la soirée nous le
placerons compagnie d'artistes également
à 23h30
angelo branduardi qui interprétera une
dizaine de chansons à 00h10 georges
brassens à qui nous rendront hommage en
rediffusant une émission que pierre
tchernia lui avait consacré en octobre
1975 pour un air de guitare autour de
georges brassens il y avait maxime le
forestier pierre louki marcel dadi roger
pierre et jean marc thibault et enfin à
1h10 avec herbert von karajan filmé par
françois reichenbach
nous verrons comment travaille le chef
d'orchestre et nous assisterons un peu
la genèse d'un concert évidemment nous
aurons l'occasion de revenir sur tous
ses rendez vous tout au long de la
journée
je voudrais vous signaler que dans
quelques instants
allons retrouver philippe bouvard c'est
là 499e fois aujourd'hui qui nous
donnent rendez vous bonne journée à tous
bonsoir et bien après les rendez-vous
radio un rendez-vous télévision celui
que vous fixent toujours à faire 3 côte
d'azur puisqu'il est 19h20 c'est donc
l'heure de vos actualités télévisées
régional ce soir c'est bernard violet et
jean-marie maingot qui vous présente les
informations de cette journée voici les
principaux titres
et ce soir à 20h30 et bien vous pourrez
suivre une nouvelle série en six
épisodes dont vous pourrez soit suivre
le premier épisode ce soir à 20h30 et le
2e demain soir s'appelle
blanc-bleu-rouge pourquoi bien parce que
blanc symbolise les chouans la monarchie
le bleu les républicains et le rouge le
sang versé pendant cette longue guerre
civile qui durera six ans et fit plus de
cinq cent mille morts
blanc bleu rouge est une série adaptée
par claude brûlé d'après le roman de
françoise linares sophie mon coeur est
réalisé par yannick andrei c'est une
histoire d'amour difficile entre un chou
ans et une jeune bourgeoise libéral le
chemin est interprété par bernard
giraudeau aux côtés de anne canovas donc
ce soir ne manquez pas le premier
épisode et demain soir le deuxième blanc
bleu rouge ensuite à 21 heures 30 ce
soir eh bien nous avons rendez vous avec
le livre avec l'émission littéraire de
georges suffert la rage de l'irc a pour
thème la révolution du livre en format
de poche 1980 est l'année internationale
des handicapés et tf1 nous propose
chaque mercredi à 13h40
une émission qui est le relais qui leur
est consacré portes ouvertes magazine de
claude rubans et de bénédicte la place
et je voudrais vous signaler dès
maintenant que les dialogues de cette
émission seront sous-titrés et puis
ensuite à partir de 13h55 bien nos
jeunes amis retrouveront les visiteurs
du mercredi l'émission de christophe
izard mais c'est une version 1981 donc
ne la manquez pas ne manquez pas cette
premier rendez-vous de 1980 les
visiteurs du mercredi tout à l'heure
donc à 13h55 dans un instant les
actualités en compagnie de jean pierre
pernaut et marie laure augry
où
via vous l'avez remarqué il nous est
impossible de continuer cette émission
louis borg on nous demande donc de vous
présenter ses excuses pour l'instant
donc voici pendant 10 minutes un court
métrage qui a pour titre l'écho visuels
nous vous tiendrons informés de la suite
du programme tout à l'heure
madame mademoiselle messieurs bonjour si
vous nous rejoignez seulement maintenant
sur antenne 2 je vous souhaite à tous et
à toutes une très bonne et très heureuse
nouvelle année il y a bien entendu un
programme de fête un programme tout à
fait exceptionnelle cet après midi sur
antenne 2 puisque nous sommes le 1er
janvier 1981 alors à partir de 14h
sachez que vous pourrez découvrir une
comédie musicale qui vous est proposée
par bruno fourcade et qui a pour titre
une brebis pas comme les autres il
s'agit d'une comédie menée avec beaucoup
de charme beaucoup de malice et
interprété par le petit conservatoire de
mireille à 15h05 notez-bien 15h05 ce
rendez vous quatre grands noms du cinéma
français seront en tête d'affiche pour
vous faire rire et ce dans le cadre de
ciné noël vous avez en effet rendez vous
avec le bossu il s'agit d'un film tourné
en 1959 par andré hunebelle est inspiré
d'un roman mélodramatique de paul féval
paru en 1858 je vous donnerai d'ailleurs
plus de détails sur ce film un petit peu
plus tard dans l'après midi lorsqu'il
sera je pense 14h à 16h45
nous nous rendrons au cirque pour voir
les prouesses du cirque barnum et à
17h50 jeunes amis oui vous avez rendez
vous avec récré a2 18h ne manquez pas le
16ème épisode dacca guerra aujourd'hui
il s'agira de découvrir une famille bien
tranquille oui en effet une famille de
treize gorille simplement donc un rendez
vous avec les animaux bien entendu avec
l'humour à partir de 18h dans l'immédiat
je vous invite à retrouver un nouveau
numéro de la série fenêtre sur une série
que vous propose chaque jour sylvie
genevoix et aujourd'hui vous allez
découvrir les pèlerins du chant choral
que se passe-t-il chaque année à vaison
la romaine qui sont ces envahisseurs qui
hante tous les lieux publics et qui
chantent
eh bien nous allons tout de suite le
découvrir dans cette émission réalisée
par henri chauffe à tout à l'heure et
bon début d'après midi
et
vous ne respectez donc rien c'est un
titre qui annonce le trait de caractère
communs à tous les écrivains présents de
ce soir donc sur le plateau d'
apostrophes à 21h40
ils seront les invités donc de bernard
pivot et puis à 23 heures et bien que
jean-philippe nous proposera à son
ciné-club le ciné-club de l'été avec un
film de jean louis trintignant et oui
vous saviez que jean-louis peut-être que
jean louis trintignant était scénariste
dialoguiste et réalisateur son premier
film il l'a réalisé en 1972 avec jacques
dufilho dans le rôle principal
il s'agit d'une journée bien remplie
donc que ce soit dans le ciné club le
ciné-club d'été à partir de 23 heures
voilà j'espère que tous ses rendez-vous
veux bien vous plairont et vous feront
passer une agréable soirée en compagnie
de patricia lucia que vous retrouverez
tout à l'heure tout à l'heure aussi dans
un petit moment
vous pourrez jouer le jeu des chiffres
et des lettres mais auparavant via
quelques petits moments où nous allons
passer ensemble et avec quelques images
très rigolote
l'amour en fuite c'est le film de
françois truffaut tourné en 1978 que
nous vous proposons à 20h30 une suite de
plus à l'itinéraire sentimental
d'antoine doinel interprété par
jean-pierre léaud le héros sherin de
françois truffaut
il est entouré de claude jeanne marie
france pisier et dorothée à 22h05 ce
sera la dernière édition de soir 3 puis
à 22h30
nous vous proposons dans la série compte
d'italie hiver de malades
un téléfilm d'alberto moravia réalisé
par carlo liddy qui retrace la vie d'un
jeune homme condamné à une cure de
soleil
nous terminerons notre soirée en musique
avec prélude à la nuit ce soir
fantasiestücke opus 88 des schumann très
bonne soirée à tous sur fr3
et bien cette soirée s'achève alors
avant de nous séparer juste un petit
coup d'oeil sur la soirée de demain dès
20h35
nous retrouvons bien sûr jean richard le
commissaire maigret dans une toute
nouvelle enquête intitulée maigri à
vichy et juste après aux alentours de
22h15 dans musique au coeur en compagnie
des morues jerry les bateaux partiront à
la recherche de stravinsky un
merveilleux conte musical inspiré des
musiques du compositeur russe et la
recherche de s aidant musique au coeur
demain soir et puis il ya un nouveau
rendez vous sur lequel j'aimerais
attirer votre attention
à partir de demain chaque dimanche à 9
heures et bien nous suivrons les
émissions religieuses connaître l'islam
la source de vie présence protestante le
jour du seigneur et la messe et la messe
noter dès maintenant
elle sera célébrée demain avec la
paroisse saint pierre saint paul de
rueil malmaison en raison donc des
émissions religieuses le premier rendez
vous de la journée avec chaque matin sur
un petit peu reculer n'entreront donc
jacques martin et toute l'équipe
d'entrée les artistes demain aux
alentours de midi pour l'instant je vous
souhaite à toutes et à tous de passer
une excellente soirée une très belle
nuit est notre prochain rendez-vous et
bien c'est demain matin à 8h30 avec le
flash à formation mais aussi avec les
chevaux dit hier c'est bon soir
décidément rien ne s'arrange dans le
feuilleton à l'eau tu m'aimes c'est une
vraie catastrophe
dans un instant le 82e épisode une
réalisation de pire gotaas à 13h30
pascal sanchez and pasteur promettent
aux 15-25 ans une pêche d'enfer il
s'agit d'une émission spéciale sports
d'hiver qui se déroulera à tignes
et dans l'immédiat la suite de votre
programme de respecter les biens qui
relèvent de sang
je vous rappelle qu'à 18h drevet vend la
mèche à 18h30 votre jeu quotidien
questions pour un champion animé par
julien lepers suivi du 19/20 premier
grand rendez vous d'information de la
soirée
mais avant tout cela nous allons
retrouver petit ours brun la dix
huitième partie des gaffeurs le dernier
épisode de tom sawyer le chevalier
lumière numéro un et l'ascenseur pour l'
aventure voici donc amusé 3 et bonne fin
d'après-midi sur fr3
ce soir au programme vous l'avez vu du
rire de la détente et surtout du cinéma
et pas n'importe lequel des cinémas
vérité à en croire le titre du film les
hommes préfèrent les grosses il comédie
vous vous retrouverez josiane balasko
dans le rôle d'une jeune fille un peu
enrobé qui a du mal à trouver et à
garder un petit ami des recettes de
régime donc où l'humour est roi à 20h45
puis à 22h15 d'un place aux coulisses du
7ème art avec cinéma cinémas deuxième
ouvrés entre autres patrick bouchitey
sur le tournage de son premier film une
interview exclusive des jarres depardieu
à propos de la nouvelle version filmée
de henry henry 5 et un plein zoom sur
les nouvelles du front et l'agenda du
mois à 20 heures le journal vous sera
présentée par philippe le fait et dans
quelques minutes nous nous retrouvons
car j'ai quelque chose d'important à
vous dire
bonjour bien réveillé moi c'est floriane
la nouvelle d'antenne 2 tout de suite
votre dernier épisode pour tout l'or du
transvaal et puis après votre animateur
chéri dans eric et toi et moi
bonne journée à tous
bonjour bonjour à tous bonjour surtout
nos jeunes amis puisque nous sommes
mercredi ils retrouveront eric noëlla et
leurs héros préférés bien sûr cet après
midi dès 14 heures 30
en ce qui nous concerne nous à partir de
12h30 et nous nous retrouverons patrice
laffont et sans jeu les mariés de la
deux et puis à 13h le journal vous sera
présentée par philippe lefait notre
soirée quant à elle commence à 20h45
avec un film de la collection contre
jour une collection dirigée par jacques
deray ce sera le premier film réalisé
pour la télévision par michel vianey la
porte d'or avec gérard klein et laure
killing mais regardez plutôt ces
quelques images
grand concours cinéma ticket star pour
cannes antennes de france soir voilà et
maintenant place au ciné club qui nous
présente ce soir candy mountain signé
rudy furent l'isère et ce film est le
premier des huit films qui vous seront
proposées dans le cadre de notre grand
concours antennes de france soir
regardez le attentivement car juste
après à la fin de ce film nous vous
poserons une question et si vous trouvez
la réponse est bien vous serez peut-être
l'heureux gagnant d'un week end pour
deux personnes au festival de cannes
1990 alors demain dont françois vous
trouverez un bulletin réponse ainsi que
le règlement complet de ce grand jeu
concours et vous pouvez également
obtenir ce règlement et envoyez votre
réponse sur papier libre bonne chance à
tous candy mountain s'est tout de suite
oui concernés firme dans deux parties
pardon tout d'abord 18h50 en intégralité
en exclusivité au viens de vous le dire
et en direct également antenne 2
retransmet en effet le discours que
nelson mandela fera à cette occasion
et puis plus tard dans la soirée à 22h10
nous rejoindrons julien clerc pour ce
concert vous l'avez vue sont réunis les
plus grandes stars internationales
mais une autre opération exceptionnelle
et d'espoir elle aussi poursuit sa route
tout au long de ce week-end pascal nous
vivons à son heure ce lundi patrice
laffont l'a dit il y a un petit instant
nous arrivons sur la route des retours
c'est un point critique
si ce n'est pas encore fait rejoignez
nous soyez prudent ne dira jamais assez
l'opération drapeau blanc continue et
maintenant je laisse la parole à daniel
duigou pour un flash info bonjour daniel